also ich finde wir sollten den Burger
die Wahrheit sagen wir wir werden alle
Bereiche müssen CO2 reduzieren weil
sonst die Erderwärmung auch in
Deutschland viel zu schlimm wird so
jetzt können wir das wie die FDP sagen
wir machen das mit Emissionshandel das
bedeutet wir Benzinpreis wird sehr
schnell Richtung 45 € gehen das wird die
FDP gar nicht machen weil sie ja schon
bei viel geringerer Höhe den Tankrabatt
eingeführt hat und den die Erhöhung des
Emissionshandel zum ersten Januar gegen
unseren Widerstand übrigens gestoppt hat
und wenn wir also was erreichen wollen
was nicht mehr kostet dann sollten wir
zumindestens mal ausprobieren ob wir
nicht ein Tempolimit auf Autobahn haben
wir sind das letzte Land in der Welt die
das nicht haben
es wird paar Millionen Tonnen CO2
einsparen wie viel genau würde man ja da
mal genau messen können und außerdem
könnte man sagen die Autos müssen kein
Tempolimit kriegen weil wir brauchen ja
kein CO2 beim Fahren so dass wir sogar
noch mal ohne dass es was kostet der
Steuerzahler ein Anreiz geben auf die
Autos sind Autos die dürfen so schnell
fahren wie sie wollen und die Verbrenner
sollen dann ausgebremst werden und damit
sp anderen CO2 glaubst du das ja wissen
Sie eigentlich wie viel Tempolimit ist
auf deutschen Autobahnen gibt ja aber es
gibt ja neue Frage wie viel wie viel
Autobahnkilometer sind noch unten
insofern ein Drittel der Autobahn
hat
ein Drittel der Autobahn hat
dauerhafte tempo-beschränkungen
ja so und dann so aber ja wenn wir durch
Bayern fahren als beispielsweise wenn
wir durch Bayern fahren Markus Süder
stellt sich immerhin gegen das
Tempolimit fahren Sie doch mit dem Auto
durch Bayern fahren Sie die
verschiedenen Autobahnen lang sie werden
ganz häufig sogar Tempolimit von 100
haben 100 12 kleiner ist doch der ist
doch die Einschränkung also um das
Argumentieren umso geringer ist doch der
Effekt das heißt wir haben ein Problem
wir haben doch ein Tempolimit und wissen
sie studieren gibt die kleinste sagt 3
Millionen Tonnen die größer gesagt 87
Studien vom Umweltbundesamt die jedes
Jahr jedes Jahr neu seit sechs Jahren
macht das Umweltbundesamt jedes Jahr
eine neue Studie immer neue Ergebnisse
aber ich habe gesagt das ist das drei
Jahre machen und genau messen dann
wissen wir es doch und was schadet jetzt
eigentlich und wir drei Jahre auf diesen
wenigen restkilometern wie sie sagen so
wenig sind es gar nicht aber ist ja egal
was ist das mal ausprobieren und dann
messen und dann wissen wir
dann gleich auf 100 gehen dann 120
gesagt aber
überhaupt gar kein Tempolimit und dann
haben wir ja aber auf 70% der Autobahn
ist aber dann gehen wir sozusagen als
Autoland Deutschland na wo so viel
abhängt von der Autoindustrie geht dann
auf ein Tempolimit runter wo wir dann
plötzlich die langsamsten Autos
Autobahnen in ganz Europa haben
die die Auto Vorstände die das früher
vertreten haben vertreten das heute gar
nicht mehr weil der drin nämlich zum
automatisierten fahren gehen und wenn
Sie das Auto selber fährt dann schaffen
Sie die hohen Temperatur gar nicht weil
sie ja ich feier natürlich ehrlich
gesagt selten Autobahn weil ich lieber
Zug fahre und in Berlin selber
jeder der Tempolimit will kann das doch
machen also auf den Strecken wo sowieso
schon tempolimitiert wird also die Frage
ist ja nicht fahren Sie doch einfach
langsamer Moment die Frage stellen
co2-bereich das kann ich nicht machen
aber selbst entscheiden entschuldige
sozusagen die Erderwärmung fragt nach
Ausstoß und wenn wir die Erderwärmung
reduzieren wollen und der Verkehrssektor
muss was beitragen dann haben Sie die
Wahl zwischen höheren Spritpreisen und
Tempolimit ich will die Entscheidung
aber jetzt beispielsweise auf 140 und
Deutschland würde dann runterfahren also
das Italien erhöht ist noch lange nicht
ausgemacht zweitens der reden wir dann
immer zehn Kilometer Tempo Unterschied
ich weiß gar nicht warum das in
Deutschland so ein emotionales Thema ist
das ist ehrlich gesagt wie beim
Rauchverbot ja also ich kann mich noch
erinnern als die Leute sich in Berlin
demonstriert haben weil sie nur noch auf
dem oberen Deck des
doppelte Fahrt das hat Tempo auf
Autobahn ist wissen sie das der das ist
unter 100 aber das weiß ich ja habe ich
heute noch mal extra vor der Sendung
nach mehrere 104 aber wir sind unter dem
tempoli mit ohnehin schon
aber ja
sofort kommen
ich war 100 aber die Schweizer kommen
auch gerne auf den deutsche Autobahn und
geben da mal Gas oder das tun sie ganz
gern es gab ja uns bei uns auch mal die
autopartei die freie Fahrt für freie
Bürger forderte aus irgendwelchen
Gründen hat die sich nicht durchgesetzt
bzw in die SVP verwandelt
es wundert mich dass wir im Tempolimit
haben und dass das doch mehrheitlich gut
eingehalten wird und ich finde es auch
richtig und ich begrüße diesen Vorschlag
also bei Ihnen auch langsam unterwegs
auch gestern über den
Koalitionsausschuss gesprochen da wurde
einiges kassiert vor allem Robert Habeck
Pläne wird das Ganze jetzt wird kann er
das nicht ganz umsetzen dann lagern wir
es ihm um auf den Verkehr und ist das
auch so ein Geschachere was dann gemacht
wird damit man dort eben die
Einsparungen die Grünen Ideen
verwirklichen kann erstaunlich wie sie
so nahe jetzt immer näher an die Grünen
herangehen jetzt auch mit dem Tempolimit
also diese unterschreiten ja quasi auch
die forder ungen
und die sagen
erstaunlich wie sie sich da so in ihren
Wunsch Ihren Wunschpartner derzeit
hinbewegen also ich glaube dass diese
ganze verbotsgeschichte
entspricht nicht meinem Naturell
deswegen bin ich die dagegen dass man
den Leuten irgendetwas vorschreibt und
es gibt ja schon sehr viele
Einschränkungen
ich bin dafür dass die Leute entscheiden
sollen wie sie waren und wenn sie wenn
sie schneller CO2 verbrauchen was wir
hier tun aber da brauchen wir mehr CO2
sind auch diesen diesen Aspekt mit der
Autoindustrie wirklichen wichtige
Geschichte und sie halten sich aber aus
ich habe gefragt
senken wenn sie keine höheren
Spritpreise und kein Tempolimit wollen
dann frage ich nicht wie wollen Sie das
denn machen naja oder wollen Sie sagen
ist egal wir verstehen jetzt CO2 aus ich
glaube man kann nicht ins Wasser
springen oder was zu reden
natürlich total viele Ideen man kann
sich an diesem Tempolimit ähm was auch
immer das einspart eine Million Tonnen
CO2 1,5 man muss wahrscheinlich jedes
Jahr die neue Umweltbundesamt Studie
lesen irgendwann kommt man dann zu einem
Wert wo man ganz vergessen
warum haben Sie eigentlich im Jahr davor
auf 1,5 Millionen also das
Umweltbundesamt
macht seit sechs Jahren jedes Jahr ein
neues Studio kommt immer zu neuen
Ergebnissen also da wäre ich sehr
vorsichtig was diese Studienergebnisse
angeht aber ich habe eine Idee und auch
Sie der Mitglied einer Partei die 2011
den endgültigen Ausstieg aus der
Kernenergie beschlossen hat wenn wir
über dieses Thema reden CO2 Vermeidung
beispielsweise und sichere Strom sichere
Stromerzeugung wenn wir auch über die
Frage reden wir sollen E-Autos die
einigermaßen günstig auch fahren und
aufgeladen werden in diesem Land fahren
lassen dann ist das Thema weniger CO2 in
der Luft und das mit Kernkraft zu
koppeln 1 was quasi auf der Hand liegt
und da ist es auch was die
Glaubwürdigkeit der CDU angeht nicht
ganz redlich immer zu sagen wir müssen
hier noch beim Mühe beim Autofahrer dann
noch sagen äh dem dem
bevormunden wir ähm und sagen das
Tempolimit ist es jetzt wenn Italien
sogar aufgeht und das Klima wird immer
global gedacht zu Recht in China zwei
Kohlekraftwerke pro Woche neu ans Netz
gehen dann können wir hier sparen und
sparen dass wir wollen falsch
so viel so da Energie und Wind Energie
wie China die wollen ja jetzt sogar den
Solar Export verbieten weil sie selber
braucht so viel Kohlekraftwerke die die
china baut noch zu viele Kohlekraftwerke
aber Zulassung zwei pro Woche aber wir
können doch nicht sie können doch nichts
also erstens ich bin ja habe ich ja
vorhin schon gesagt ich bin ja für die
Verlängerung der bestehenden nur die
bringen also wir können die drei die wir
noch haben verlängern
die ähm wir können doch nicht sagen der
Verkehr verlagert das nämlich das was
die Bundesregierung jetzt macht am Ende
wird die Industrie den Preis zahlen wir
werden aber mehr Arbeitslosigkeit
kriegen weil wir werden die Klimaziele
nur einhalten können wir mit den
industrialisieren das ist der dann der
de facto Weg alles andere ist wir werden
ja wieder bei den Gebäuden vor innerhalb
von 20 Jahren alle Heizungen austauschen
noch wird die Landwirtschaft das Liefern
also wird die Industrie liefern müssen
und wenn es die Industrie liefert weil
wir das im Verkehr nicht machen dann
müssen wir nur wissen was wir tun dann
sitzen dann ist die Autoindustrie erst
richtig betroffen deswegen hatte ich das
für Unsinn und Sie können das ist
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich die Frage was
wollen sie im Verkehr tun sagen sie
Atomkraftwerke
der Klimaschutz macht doch keinen
Unterschied zwischen Sektor der sagt
doch nicht weil in der Industrie mehr
eingespart wurde und im Verkehr weniger
als
geplant im Verkehr
weil wir mehr Autos fahren und größere
Autos fahren und mehr Kilometer fahren
ja auch wo die Bevölkerung gar nicht so
sehr steigt nicht brechen dann haben wir
Probleme Unterstützung haben Sie denn in
der eigenen Partei wenn Sie jetzt mit
Friedrich Merz beispielsweise das
Tempolimit sprechen
ist dafür noch nicht die Klima AG also
die die sich von morgens bis abends mit
Kindern und Energie beschäftigen die die
sind mehrheitlich dafür also eine kleine
AG ist dafür
Arbeitsgruppen Fachgruppen und die
Fachgruppe in der Bundestagsfraktion für
Klima und Energie ist dafür mehrheitlich
aber
in der Partei ist es noch keine mehr
aber ich mache das ja nicht weil sie
Wahrheit ist oder weil es die Grünen
sagen sondern weiß für seiner Sache
richtig
meinen Kindern ehrlich gesagt nicht eine
überhitzte Erde da stellen ich glaube
Leute haben keine Ahnung was das
wirklich heißt das klingt ja immer so
wenig hier in Berlin wo wir gerade sind
war vor
20.000 Jahren die Temperaturen nur vier
Grad kälter aber wir hatten 200 m Eis
die Nordsee gab es nicht England war
keine Insel die Ostsee war ein kleines
Binnengewässer das machen wir gerade aus
damit man sich einfach mal vorstellt was
das für dramatische Veränderungen sind
die werden so teuer werden 3 Milliarden
Menschen der Welt haben die nicht da
wohnen bleiben können wo sie heute
wohnen das wird alles so viel Geld
kosten jetzt nicht sagen na ja also ich
habe irgendwie passt uns beides nicht
vor Spritpreis nicht und ja 120 nicht
aber wir lassen diese Gefahren
die Wahrheit sagen dass wir leider in
Deutschland die Klimaziele auch im
letzten Jahr erreicht hat müssen wir
einfach das wird immer so getan
20% Rückgang in der Industrie hatten
wegen des Ukraine Kriegs ohne die wäre
die Klimaziele locker gerissen worden
und im Verkehr an der Gebäude haben
so dass wenn du zuhörst dass du nichts
ein Mensch da ist ja die Ampel fast
besser ist wenn
äh schwarz grün kommt ich glaube dass
der die Sektor Einteilung nicht ganz
nicht ganz richtig ist weil Klima wie
wir wissen auch in Europa ja nicht vor
der deutschen Landesgrenze Grenze Halt
macht und wenn in Polen Kohle verfeuert
wird dann ist das insgesamt für die
Verschmutzung schlecht aber nicht für
die deutsche Luft alleine und die
polnische Luft sondern das ist ja ein
globales Problem und insofern ist es
glaube ich tut man sich nicht unbedingt
einen Gefallen wenn man Sektor Ziele
macht das glaube ich zumindest die Frage
ist weicht man sie auf die Frage ist
wollen wir Fahrverbote hinnehmen
beispielsweise wollen wir wie sie sagen
der Industrie mehr zumuten das sind
alles Dinge die kann man diskutieren und
man muss sich glaube ich immer der
Folgekosten am Ende bewusst sein ich
finde zum Beispiel einen bestätigen
Anstieg was Benzinpreise anregt durchaus
in Ordnung weil es den Menschen die
Freiheit gut zu sagen nein auf vier Euro
von vier Euro hat aber im nächsten Jahr
auch niemand gesprochen ich weiß nicht
ob sie das wollen aber der CO2-Anstieg
so wie er geplant ist der Aufschlag
bedeutet ja nicht der Liter für Euro
aber ich sage Ihnen auch was anderes das
was jetzt passiert mit den Wärmepumpen
so wie es aufgesetzt ist das ist doch
kein Wort billiger wenn Robert Habeck
verspricht die soziale Abfederung soll
so laufen dass der Einbau einer neuen
Wärmepumpe 25 bis 30 000 € genauso teuer
ist wieder Einbau einer gastheizung 7
bis 8000 €, dann reden wir hier bei
klein und mittleren Einkommen über
Budgets von 20 bis 25000 €, die der
Steuerzahler finanzieren muss pro
Haushalt oder Autoverkehr weil sie
gerade sagen ob ich das möchte dass
Benzin so teuer wird die die Frage ist
doch die Kosten entstehen so und so und
jetzt ist nur die Frage mache ich es
planwirtschaftlich planwirtschaftlerisch
indem ich per beverbote Befehle was zu
tun ist oder mache ich es lasse ich den
Menschen die Freiheit zu sagen ich stoße
jetzt mein Auto weil mir das nach und
nach zu teuer wird oder ich kaufe mir
lieber jetzt eine neue Heizung weil mir
das und das zu teuer wird also befehle
ich das oder gebe ich den Menschen rein
und da wäre mein Einsatz immer zu sagen
ich mache das gebt den Menschen die
Freiheit selbst zu entscheiden
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie